and here's a fellow up here and this
looks like it's an organ and shout out
to this guy for a recording his video
and landscape horizontally that's
preferred okay what appeal what a
branded debate club big spoon verse
little spoon personally modern feminist
I'm okay with being that little spoon
hitter wearing that female like a
backpack let me know what you think gang
gang but snugs nuts to butts bro I like
being the big spoon man I'm old school
yeah feel real weird being the little
spoon you know yeah I like me in a moan
silverware drawer really I really do man
I like making sure that the other person
is happy and has a bed and a place to
sleep and then I like to sleep in my
space like to be that single spoon yeah
I like to be in the dishwasher yeah what
about you can't what's going on from the
woman's perspective
um well from my experience the tougher a
guy tries to act out in public he loves
being a little spoon in private yeah and
then it's the reverse of a guy's kind of
chill he's cool being a big spoon Wow
mmm I feel like cats can date a guy
where they hear a noise might check it
out can you go check it out go see what
that was like y'all go see what it was
hopefully it's a [ __ ] tougher man
[Laughter]
Chappelle what do you think I love you
like throw these softballs up to
Chappelle man strikes out dude I love it
I get so excited text me
Sheila's text you little spoon
that's what I'm talking about anger
issues wanna be a little yeah Nick you
got a girl you trying to snuggle up you
so I like back i like being big spoon
when we're cuddling but when it's time
to go to sleep i need to turn over and
if she wants to drape or arm around me
that's fine like III like it I'm like we
can we can touch but like I gotta go to
sleep so like I can't fall asleep yeah
that's not your space for kids yeah for
high school kids that are dating each
other and that know each other well but
they're both 15 yeah yeah clear yeah we
my girlfriend wanted to experiment being
the big spoon oh yes bro
it was my bird it was my birthday my
girl got real freaky man she decided I
was gonna be the little spoon bunch of
[ __ ] I gotta let her do it I let her
do it she wanted to do it so I let her
do it and then she liked it but I was
like it doesn't feel right so I'm always
the big spoon of yeah it just doesn't
feel normal doesn't feel right it's got
that yeah I think maybe if it's a if
it's for warmth or something like that
maybe or you're stuck trapped somewhere
outside you've got locked out of the
house or something out to sleep outside
yeah it's like a negative Freight
situation then we're going to tease the
back you feel me I'm yeah stay warm wear
it like a blanket but a normal house god
dude
I need my space I'm not trying to be no
spoon I'm with you on this I want my own
bedroom on my own bathroom me to do I'm
not trying to hold a fart in all night
either come on no dude I see date this
card to go fart on the balcony sometimes
I do this I do the silencer I put that
[ __ ] pillow to my ass maybe maybe the
old silencer did the class
move dude when I first yes I live in a
studio in Marina del Rey I lived in a
studio in the bathroom it was tiny the
bathroom's right next to right next to
the [ __ ] bedroom
dude I was dating this girl she went in
and blew that [ __ ]
yeah there's no silence in that uh oh my
god
disturbing dude yeah dude every time I
hear a girl fart or something just part
of me died it'll ruin your day bro one
bedroom studio some girl blows that
pressure starts playing them toilet
trumpets next to your bad dude bro water
one time I was high on drugs and I was
in England actually somewhere in England
and uh I saved this girl's place and I
thought she'd fallen asleep so I went to
the bathroom to do number two do a stool
sure and sometimes just got it and so
I'm in there for like 40 minutes doing
there like British literature and stuff
I'm reading up you know yeah getting to
know you know getting familiar with the
continent or whatever yeah and and I
come out and she'd been awake the whole
time I didn't by myself in her bathroom
for 40 minutes like I had say pee you
know oh there was a line you know when I
do I used to I used to run the shower
well I run the shower man cuz then you
got this you have hide the smell and
[ __ ] it's exhausting wasting water
brothers people in countries they don't
have any water Hey yeah using water to
mask a stool whatever it takes all right
I was I was about to turn into that
Kimbo Slice joke again if you didn't
come
[Music]
the king
[Music]